the Argentine government was forced to
take drastic measures after an already
weak pace or has in recent weeks taken a
pounding against the US dollar central
bank reserves are dwindling as it
consistently keeps propping the currency
up googly-eye sees what the controls do
is precisely to maintain those reserves
putting limits on eventual dollarization
but with unfettered availability of the
equity of each argentine president
Mauricio Macri called an emergency
cabinet meeting first thing on Monday
after publishing the new measures over
the weekend in the official government
bulletin both the markets and most
Argentines crave is a stable economy
what they have is uncertainty both
economically and politically that they
suffered and overcome some of the crisis
before is at the moment of little
consolation Argentines are still haunted
by memories of the 2001 2002 crisis when
savers will prevent it from withdrawing
their own money from banks thousands of
businesses went under and millions slid
into poverty the whole country is now
watching and waiting nervously to see
whether the new measures will work it
takes you back to earlier times in the
2001 default you start distrusting banks
if you have money then perhaps you want
to take it out you would throw it from
the bank you take it home and you hold
on to it out of concern because we've
had similar situations in the past yes
embassy I don't have deposits in dollars
I have savings in dollars but I haven't
deposited them because two years ago I
started to sense that something smelled
wrong you didn't see Munem Macri was
supposed to be Argentina's market
friendly salvation to tackle rampant
inflation what this government did was
prioritized inflation above everything
else and we have what we have today so
you have the economy to stand still you
have a technical default you have a run
on the peso you're in the worst of all
possible worlds add to that least
growing unemployment and poverty and a
huge debt to the International Monetary
Fund the electorate spoke at primary
elections last month suggesting Mac
Lee's economic policies have failed and
that they want to rid
to a more socially conscious government
in October's presidential elections the
president is meanwhile trying to
convince both the Argentine people and
the markets that he can do in just a few
weeks when he's not been able to do in
the past four years
Daniel Schwalm there al Jazeera won
Osiris